the Commissioner of US Customs and
Border Protection is ordering new steps
to protect children in US custody after
the death of an eight-year-old
Guatemalan boy Felipe Gomez Alonso died
just before midnight on Christmas Eve he
is the second migrant child to die this
month after being detained near the
border that's right the first
seven-year-old jackeline call also from
Guatemala was buried yesterday in her
hometown she died in a u.s. detention
facility from dehydration and septic
shock Janet shamlian is in Alamogordo
New Mexico at the hospital where this
latest boy died Janet good morning good
morning to you this is the hospital
where Felipe was treated and ultimately
died late on Christmas Eve he'd arrived
in the United States about a week
earlier with his father reportedly in
good health before being taken into US
custody so what happened here well this
morning we have new information on a
death some are calling an outrage
Customs and Border Protection now
reports that at about nine o'clock
Christmas Eve morning detention center
agents noticed eight-year-old Felipe
Gomez Alonso coughing and appeared to
have glassy eyes by 12:45 he was at the
hospital diagnosed and treated for a
common cold at 120 he registered a
103-degree fever but by 250 he and his
father were released from the ER and
transferred to another checkpoint with a
prescription for an antibiotic and
ibuprofen
officials say the pair received several
welfare checks there but by 7:00 that
night the boy's condition worsened he
appeared to be nauseous and vomited but
his father declined further medical
assistance
three hours later authorities say Felipe
was lethargic and nauseous again an
agent sent him back to the hospital as
there was no EMT on duty on the way he
lost consciousness could not be revived
and was pronounced dead at 11:48 p.m.
this administration has put deterrence
and enforcement ahead of humane
treatment of people Chris Richert is
counsel for the American Civil Liberties
Union which is suing the government over
its immigration policies Texas
congressman better or work spoke
yesterday about the
child's death I'm gonna call for an
investigation just to get to the facts
make sure we understand what happened
and to prevent something like that from
happening again Alonso was a second
child from Guatemala to die in Border
Protection's custody this month on
Monday family members wept as the body
of seven year old Jacqueline call was
returned home Rickard says the
Department of Homeland Security and the
President must be held accountable the
question is what does it take for DHS to
take action how many more children have
to die before they are not put in these
conditions the hospital cited privacy
concerns for not giving out more
information about Philippe's death but
they do say an autopsy is being done to
learn how he died meanwhile Customs and
Border Protection says it isn't doing
its own investigation and as of this
morning the agency has ordered new
wellness checks on every child currently
in its custody with an emphasis on those
under the age of 10 Tony